hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast acoustic experience
alters how you see the world presented
by dr. Stephen lumber a Canada Research
Chair in brain plasticity and
development and a professor of
physiology pharmacology and psychology
at University of Western Ontario I'm
Susie Valdez elaborate and I'll be your
moderator for today's event we're
delighted to bring you this educational
web seminar presented by lab roots
labret is a leading scientific social
networking website and producer of
educational and virtual events and
webinars before we begin I want to
remind everyone that this event is
interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want at any time you
want during the presentation just click
on the ask a question box located on the
far left of your screen and type your
questions into the drop down box that
appears on that screen we'll answer as
many questions as we have time for at
the end of the presentation if you have
any trouble hearing or seeing the
presentation click on the help desk
button located in the promotional board
at the bottom center of the screen or
use that ask a question box to let us
know you're having a problem also this
presentation is educational and that
offers continuing education credits
click on the continuing education
credits tab that's located on the top
right corner of the presentation window
and follow the process for obtaining
your credits without further ado please
join me in welcoming our presenter today
dr. Stephen lumber I will now turn the
presentation over to him
welcome sir thank you very much
today we'll be talking a little bit
about brain and organization and
cortical plasticity and we'll explain a
little bit about the work we do here in
our lab I'd like to start with an
overview of the cerebral cortex this
organization and some of the plasticity
we work we understand already so what
you see here is a dorsal view of the
human brain basically looking down from
the top and this is
the classic view that many of us think
of when we think of the human cerebral
cortex but unfortunately you're really
only looking at a small portion of the
cortex when you look at the brain from
this view very little the cerebral
cortex is action the surface of the
brain
the vast majority of the cerebral cortex
is actually buried deep down into the
salsa that you can see on this
horizontal section so what you see on
the right hand side is a dorsal or a top
view of the brain that's been cut along
the red line on the left hand side of
the slide and the top of the brain has
been lifted off and you can actually see
down into the substance of the brain
itself so what you're looking at here is
mainly gray matter of the cerebral
cortex
and underlying white matter and you can
see how the thin gray line or the thin
kind of covering is the the gray matter
of the cerebral cortex and in the human
brain is only about 2 to 3 millimeters
thick
but you can see how deep it penetrates
into the brain if we use the estimates
of Ted Jones and Alan Peters and can
actually roll out the entire human
cerebral cortex to make it into a thin
sheet you'd actually find that the
entire size of the human cerebral cortex
is about the size of a small dining room
table so it's a very large sheet a very
large thin sheet of neurons
that's compacted into a very small space
because it's kind of folded up like a
radiator inside the human head another
important thing we know about the
cerebral cortex is functional
specialization over time we've learned
that different sensory motor and
cognitive functions are localized
different parts of the human brain such
that if you look towards the right-hand
side of this left slide area 17-18 would
be where primary visual cortex is
localized or area 41 towards the center
is where primary auditory cortex is
localized or towards the top of the
slide areas 3 1 & 2 is where primary
somatosensory or touch cortex is
localized as neuroscientist this affords
us a great opportunity to be able to
look for particular functions in
particular parts of the brain but it
also has a downside and that is we know
that focal regions of damage can have
devastating functional consequences so a
stroke that's localized over reaching a
visual
tax or localized of a region of motor
cortex can have profound visual or motor
impairments per se today we're going to
be talking about cortical plasticity and
the definition I'll be using for
cortical plasticity is that it's changes
that occur in the function and
organization of the cerebral cortex is a
consequence of experience now experience
can be a very broad word often you can
think of an experience as learning a
second language or learning to play a
new sport today we'll be using it in the
term of the presence or absence of a
particular sense so we'll be talking
about it in terms of the presence of
hearing or the absence of hearing such
as deafness or the presence of vision or
the absence of vision such as blindness
a much that we've learned about cortical
plasticity was based upon the pioneering
work of David Hubel and Torsten Wiesel
who were examining visual cortex and
cats and monkeys in this slide you can
see some of their seminal anatomical
work where they injected radioactive
amino acids in this case prolene into
the eye of a monkey so you can see the
monkey brain in the upper left hand
corner with a kind of a syringe as if
it's going into the right eye the
radioactive substance was then taken up
by the ganglion cells in the eye and
transported intra greatly to the LGN
which you can see is a nissl stain
section on the right hand side of this
line the radioactive amino acid was then
taken up by the neurons that reside in
the LGN and then transported up to
primary visual cortex which can kind of
see illustrated on the top of the slide
when they processed visual cortex for
the presence of this label and
particularly in layer for visual cortex
what they found is what you see in the
upper right-hand side this kind of zebra
stripe pattern of labeling in the visual
cortex where regions that appear white
were regions where there were in receipt
of projections from the injected eye and
the regions that appear darker or black
were regions that were in receipt of
projections from the non injected eye so
you can see a kind of a loose 50-50
distribution in the kind of presence of
the tracer in visual cortex and how it
kind of alternates
a quite black-white so forth this is a
really compelling finding in its own but
then they took it a step further and
wanted to look at how modifiable these
projections might be so what they did
with some newborn monkeys was to suture
one eyelid closed and then let the
animal undeveloped for some period of
time basically only seeing through one
eye and then they applied the exact same
tracer to the open or the good eye and
when they did that they found the
pattern of labeling and you see in the
lower section on the right hand side
where now the visual cortex is almost
completely in receipt of projections
from the good or the open eye and in
fact there very few projections from the
closed or the bad eye so this I really
showed a profound demonstration about
plastic the anatomical projections are
on the visual system in a primate then
they obviously took the next step and
then reopened the closed eye and found
that the pattern would go back to where
you see in the top the top section after
a period of time and you can actually go
back and forth modifying these
projections until you reached a
particular time and development which
then became known as a critical period
mainly being that before this critical
period of time and development the
projections are modifiable but then once
you reach the end of this developmental
window basically you could think of the
projections were locked in for the
remainder of the animal's life
and these experiments launched literally
a thousand studies in ocular dominance
plasticity as it's known but there was a
downside of these experiments they also
led us to believe that this kind of
plasticity was only afforded early in
development there wasn't any sort of
cortical plasticity later on obviously
over time we found this isn't to be true
but these experiments are extremely
important nonetheless a little bit more
recent for those studies were so with
some work done in mycommerce next lab
the University of California and San
Francisco where he was examining the
brains of adolescent owl monkeys so at
the top of this picture you can see the
brain of an owl monkey and he was
specifically looking at somatosensory
cortex so you can see here
we're the representation of the body and
the face would be on the cerebral cortex
an owl monkey and they've mapped out the
representation of the five fingers of
the owl monkey that you can see in the
bottom left and on the right hand side
you can actually see how those five
digits were represented in the cerebral
cortex digits of one through five and it
almost looks like a hand laid over the
surface of the brain so they identified
where the representation of the five
digits are in somatosensory cortex and
then they asked the simple question of
what would happen up following
amputation or what happens to the
representation of the hand if one digit
went missing so they did this experiment
and what they found is in the upper left
you can see the animal with its digits 1
2 4 and 5 but with a third digit missing
and after several months they went and
recorded from somatosensory cortex from
this animal and what they found was that
there wasn't a region that was no longer
responsive to tactile stimuli in fact
what had happened was the representation
from the second the fourth digit
actually expanded into the territory
that would previously occupy the
representation of the third digit and
that's actually correlated with enhanced
sensitivity and the second and fourth
digit presumably because it was more now
more cortical territory dedicated to
processing that information the another
interesting thing to see though is
overall the hand representation didn't
get any larger I was pretty much the
same size as the hand representation as
before it's just that there was now more
cortical territory dedicated to
processing information from the second
and the fourth digit even more recently
was work from Joseph's brow checkers lab
this work is a little bit different from
the previous two studies we were just
talking about in the previous two
studies we were looking at competition
within the visual system and competition
within the somatosensory system and this
study we're actually looking at
competition between sensory systems so
here you can see in the upper picture is
an outline drawing of the cat cerebral
cortex and there's one area that's kind
of highlighted with the yellow blue and
red this is the anterior rectus Oviatt
sulcus and then the lower two panels on
the left is and
animal and on the right is this region
in a blind animal so what you see under
the intact is what's unique about this
area is that you have three relatively
you know modal sensory fields living in
close proximity to each other so in
yellow you have a somatosensory region
and blue is an auditory region and red
as a visual region in these studies what
the investigator had done was to do
bilateral eyelid suture and have the
animals live for some period of time
without receiving any normal visual
input and what was found was that the
normally visually responsive region is
shown in red and the left panel now
became acoustically responsive in the as
shown in the right panel and this was
actually correlated with an increased
auditory spatial sensitivity found in
these animals and then they were much
better at localizing acoustic stimuli
than they were or found in a normal
intact animal and this has led to the
idea of what we refer to as adaptive
cross-modal plasticity and anecdotally
you probably know of this phenomenon
with things like or individuals such as
the blind piano tutor who has an
exquisite sense of pitch and has COO
stick abilities that are much much
greater than vidual who's normally
sighted but the idea is that following
the impairment of a sensory system such
as blindness or deafness it is the
enhanced perceptual performance
identified in the remaining systems
whereby one or more modalities
compensates for loss of another modality
another example of this was the work
done from Franco laborious lab at the
University of Montreal where they
studied enhanced auditory spatial
localization in the blind very similar
to the cat work we just saw previously
from the raw checker lab in our own lab
we've been studying audition and vision
and cats as well here you can see a
picture of the auditory cortex of a cat
and these large area and yellow is what
would normally be auditory cortex of a
hearing animal in the area outlined in
orange is what normally would be visual
cortex so this is how under conditions
of normal development the cerebral
cortex was set up but the question we've
been asking is absent normal hearing
such as Anakin Jenna
Daffy Apple what actually happens to
this underutilized region of auditory
cortex since it's no longer in receipt
of auditory projections do other
modalities or other senses such as
vision and somatic sensation exploit
this underutilized area to enhance the
perceptual abilities of say vision or
some medicines ation okay about ten
years ago a really fantastic review
article came out by Daphnia Valli and
her colleagues which appeared in trends
in cognitive science and asked the
simple question do deaf individuals seem
better and what this was was a
meta-analysis of all of the human
psychophysical literature done hand
congenitally deaf subjects up to that
point and what she found was that you
don't have a general enhancement in
visual abilities in the deaf we have our
enhancement of specific visual abilities
and she found that there were very
profound findings and/or improvements in
visual orienting and reorienting in a
visual motion processing and in visual
stimulus onset detection and this was an
important review paper for us because it
helped guide our own studies into this
topic so the three points I'd like to
make with you today and hopefully you'll
remember our first off is that can
generally deaf cats have specific visual
abilities they're superior to hearing
cats but it's not going to be a general
improvement it's going to be specific
visual abilities as outlined by the
Pahlavi a study ii regions of deaf
auditory cortex that is regions of the
brain that would normally be auditory
cortex in a hearing animal are
responsible for mediating the enhanced
visual abilities of the congenitally
deaf and finally the cross modal
reorganization that can generally deaf
switches the sensory but not the
behavioral roles of auditory cortex
we'll look at this more specifically a
little bit okay so what this picture is
is a cat brain kind of shown in the
foreground so you can see the cerebral
cortex the cerebellum behind that and
the spinal cord behind that superimposed
on a cat skull superimposed on a cat
head so you can see kind of relative
relative to each other where the cat
cerebral cortex in the brain
in total actually resides in the head of
cat the animal we're specifically going
to be talking about today is the
congenitally deaf cat otherwise known as
the deaf white cat these cats have a
very characteristic phenotype and are
special compared to most cats they're
going to have white fur either long hair
is shown in the upper left hand corner
or short hair in the lower right
but what usually tends to make that
quite unique is that they have two blue
eyes so if you have a cat that has white
fur and two blue eyes there's about a
seventy-five to eighty percent chance
that it was born deaf and has never
heard we obviously confirmed this with
auditory brainstem responses shortly
after the animals are born all of our
animals are derived from a breeding
colony and hanover germany directed by
andrei crowe who's in the picture with
myself in the upper right hand corner
a couple things important things to
point out about these animals are first
off they don't have any Siamese traits
or albino traits there actually have
very normal visual systems both Siamese
an albino cats have unusual visual
systems other words these cats just have
very low levels of melatonin and they
can actually be born just deaf in one
ear it could be a case where an animal
can be born with a blue one blue eye and
will hear in the ear it's a lateral to
the blue eye or on the same side and if
they have a brown eye on the other side
they may actually be able to hear
through the ear that skips led up to the
brown eye so they can be both
bilaterally deaf as you can see with the
animals here that have two blue eyes but
they also could be born with one brown
eye and one blue eye okay so the first
set of experiments we're going to talk
about will be examining dorsal stream
functions following deafness and streams
and in cortex were first established in
visual cortex the dorsal stream being
more spatial in nature and the ventral
stream being more perceptual in nature
the so-called where and what pathways so
we're going to consider where type
functions in the first set of
experiments and what type functions of
the second set of experiments so the two
aims we're going to look at are first to
determine what dorsal stream visual
abilities may actually
enhanced as a consequence of deafness
and second to determine what role death
auditory cortex may play in mediating
these superior visual functions so
basically the progress for these studies
are the white cats and hearing cats are
born deafness and hearing is then
confirmed with auditory brainstem
responses at one month of age to
establish the presence of hearing or
absence of hearing after reaching
maturity about one year of age you're
going to start training and testing and
a battery of visual tasks then we're
going to implant cooling loops over
desired regions of deaf or hearing
auditory cortex to permit their vocal
reversal deactivation will see that
precisely in a little bit they're gonna
test all cats on all tasks they're a
reversible deactivation of each cortical
locus at the end we perform a cube
cortical recording selected
physiologically and pathway tracer
injections to look at anatomical
rewiring and then perfused and process
the tissue okay so the first aim is to
determine what dorsal stream of the
visual abilities may be enhanced as a
consequence of deafness so to do this
we're going to cycle physically test
both deaf and hearing cats on battery of
visual tasks to ascertain what visual
abilities are actually enhanced there's
a consequence of deafness
in this study we're gonna look at seven
different cycle physical tasks vernier
acuity and gradient purity to look at
sharpness of vision orientation
discrimination the direction of visual
motion a velocity of motion
discrimination the detection of movement
and detection across the visual field so
to cut to the chase of all these seven
tasks most were the same between both
the hearing and the deaf populations but
the two that were different were the
detection of movement and detection
across the visual field for these two
tasks the Deaf animals had an advantage
or a superiority to the hearing animals
so let's look at those two tests
specifically first detection across the
visual field in the left hand side
you'll see an arena with an animal
standing in the center the animals
attention is drawn by the illumination
of a red LED at the zero position and
then that is extinguished and another
red LED is flashed somewhere one of the
different 15-degree positions around the
arena in this case you can kind of see
how rate 75 is indicated to have flashed
the animal that Orient's
towards it approaches it receives a food
reward we see on the left-hand side as a
polar plot kind of looking down upon the
apparatus from above so you can imagine
the cat's head at the zero percent
correct position and the length of each
green line indicates percent correct for
the hearing cats for the different
spatial positions and the red extensions
show how much better the deaf cats did
in comparison to the hearing animals so
you really see out the far periphery 60
75 90 degrees on both sides but the
death cats were significantly better
since we didn't find any difference
between the left or the right sides if
we collapse across and now look just
eccentricity with from 0 to 90 the types
of the green bars are percent correct
the different spatial positions for the
hearing cats and the height of the red
bars are the abilities or the percent
correct of the deaf animals so here you
can see for the central positions there
was no difference between the hearing
and the deaf populations but if you went
out to the far peripheral positions 60
75 90 degrees you can see how much
better the deaf animals did and the
other task detection of movement in this
case the animals are in a two
alternative forced choice apparatus
where they stick their head into a small
box and their two nose press keys a one
in front of a left stimulus one in front
of a rights they must and they see a
food reward from below when they make
the correct choice in this experiment
they had to select or their two options
were a field of stationary dots in a
field of coherently moving very slow
dots and very very slow and their task
was to identify which field was actually
in motion and this was done through a
staircase procedure where basically as
they did better and better the dots
would move slower and slower until we
could actually determine what the
threshold or what their best performance
was and in this case we found the best
performance for the hearing animals was
around one point three to one point four
degrees a second but the death cats
actually had much lower thresholds at
down around 0.5 degrees a second so the
deaf animals could actually detect much
slower speeds than the hearing cats
could which would obviously be a
performance advantage
okay so to summarize to this point the
congenitally deaf cats had visual
abilities that were similar to hearing
cats on the vast majority of the of the
task that we examine however the
congenital cats had visual abilities
that were superior to the hearing cats
specifically on the detection of
movement and visual detection the
peripheral field now in the second part
of this study we're actually gonna look
at where these visual abilities may
actually be taking place so a name - we
want to determine what role deaf
auditory cortex may play in mediating
these superior visual functions so to do
that we're going to deactivate specific
sites and death auditory cortex while
the Deaf cats perform the visual tasks
for which they possess these enhanced
visual abilities okay so in this study
we're going to examine four different
areas in the presumptive dorsal stream
of auditory cortex a primary auditory
cortex shown as a one the anterior
auditory field AF the posterior auditory
field
PAF and the dorsal zone indicated as DZ
so to do this rather than taking a
traditional lesion approach and having
to use large numbers of animals we
actually use the reversible deactivation
technique that we've a champion in our
own lab or the cryo loop technique this
can originally be found at a 1999
Journal of Neuroscience methods paper
it's quite simple
basically a methanol is drawn from a
reservoir and then pumped through a
methanol and dry ice bath that's around
minus 80 degrees Celsius
it's then exported to the device that's
implanted over the over a discreet
region of the cerebral cortex where then
cools the brain and then methanol is
returned basically what you're doing is
it inducing a smaller region of focal
hypothermia basically chilling a small
region of the brain turning the cells
off but the interesting thing is that
isn't that you can turn the cells off
the interesting thing is when you stop
pulling the neurons begin firing like
normal again
so you're basically rendering in region
of the brain silent and then turning it
back on on the left hand side you can
actually see one of these devices that
have been fabricated for a placement
over a particular region of the brain
local excuse me hypodermic stainless
steel tubing is shaped to conform to a
particular region of the brain and when
you see the arrow pointing at loop that
would be the region in contact with the
cortical surface you can also see a
copper colored wire leading up to the
blue plug which is where the thermometer
would plug in and monitor the
temperature at the point called TC or
thermocouple and if you look at the top
you can see the inflow and outflow of
the methanol and then a protective cap
that goes over the whole thing would
basically protect those two tubes when
the animal is actually being tested now
there are a couple things you need to
know about reversible cooling
deactivation first off tissue
temperatures below 20 degrees Celsius
eliminate synaptic transmission so if
you deactivate any any region of the
brain to below 20 degrees Celsius you'll
eliminate synaptic transmission however
you don't impair underlying EXO mo
transmission mainly because the myelin
over axons really protects them or
shields them from any sort of cooling so
you might actually turn off the neurons
in an area that you're interested in but
you won't interfere with underlying
fibers of passage the deactivation is
highly localized during the whole time
you're performing a coolant activation a
warm blood is being pumped in you trance
and so forth
so the cooling doesn't actually spread
very far at all
generally only 1 to 1.5 millimeters away
from the loop the activation can be
induced or reversed within minutes which
has really beneficial particularly for
behavioral studies each animal serves
its own control so from each animal you
can actually deactivate multiple
cortical sites you can also get both
control and experimental data from each
animal so this dramatically reduces the
animals they actually need to train or
have participate in your studies and
finally for us multiple cortical sites
can be examined each animal so we can
actually examine more than one area per
animal in this case in these studies
we're going to examine four different
ant areas in each animal okay what you
see here are the like the sites of four
different loops in the upper left hand
panel and then the temperature
recordings that were taken at over 300
sites across
auditory cortex which were recorded
basically with the device that looks
like just like an electrode but it's
basically used for temperature
monitoring so here you can see the
actual temperature range on the scale on
the right hand side and once again the
important thing to know is where 20
degrees Celsius is so from light to dark
blue you could actually see these would
be the regions that are deactivated so
for the anterior auditory field you can
see how well localized the region of
cooling is for a1 you can see how well
localized the region of cooling is and
then also for the dorsal zone and panel
II and then finally for the posterior
auditory field what's interesting about
the loop that was in the posterior
auditory field it is it actually
descends down into the sulcus and had a
heat shielding compound applied to its
anterior side so in this case the
cooling was only on the posterior bank
of the sulcus and not on the anterior
bank of the sulcus okay so now let's
look at performance with our tasks so in
this case we're looking at detection
across the visual field and the first
thing we're going to do is deactivate
all four sites simultaneously so we're
gonna see if there's any sort of effect
on performance when we deactivate all
four of these fields at the same time so
this seemed like the prudent thing to do
before actually doing individual
deactivations
so in this case you can see the height
of the red bars are performance of the
Deaf animals and the height of the blue
bars are performance of the deaf animals
while all four areas were simultaneously
to activate or pooled that's why they're
shown in blue so what you see here is
there's no effect on the central
positions but on those three peripheral
positions 60 75 ninety degrees you can
see how performance drops when all four
areas are simultaneously deactivated
this then basically gave us permission
to go through go and do the individual d
activations of each area so here you can
see in the top panel of the bilateral
individual deactivation of the posterior
auditory field down from that is the
dorsal zone below that a1 and finally at
the bottom the anterior auditory field
what you see is there was no change
in performance for three of the four
areas but for the top panel for the
posterior auditory field you can see
that there's a significant drop in
performance for the three peripheral
positions and in fact the entire deficit
we saw during deactivation of all four
areas could be attributed to just the
deactivation of the posterior auditory
field but the neat thing is only do the
comparison so here you can see the
results of bilateral deactivation of the
posterior auditory field in comparison
to the other results so here the green
bars indicate performance of the hearing
animals the red bars indicate
performance of the deaf animals and the
blue bars indicate performance of the
deaf animals during a bilateral
deactivation of the posterior auditory
field so what you can see is the
excellent or enhanced performance of the
deaf animals and how this enhancement
was removed when the posterior auditory
field is bilaterally deactivated and in
fact the entire advantage of the deaf
animals head was eliminated during a
bilateral deactivation of the posterior
auditory field performance didn't get
any worse than normal hearing animals as
you would expect but the performance
advantage was completely eliminated now
an interesting question to ask is why
the posterior auditory field what is
unique about the posterior auditory
field or what do we already know well
from previous work that we've done in
the lab and hearing animals we found
that bilateral deactivation of the
posterior auditory field has a profound
impairment in sound localization or the
localization of an acoustic stimulus so
if you look at the middle bottom panel
you can see how poor poorly the animals
do during bilateral deactivation in the
posterior auditory field in comparison
to normal performance in the upper three
panels so in hearing animals the
posterior auditory field makes a
significant contribution to auditory
localization but in this population of
congenital death panels what we find is
the posterior auditory field is making
an important contribution to enhanced
visual localization abilities now what
about the other tasks the detection of
movement once again we're going to
deactivate all four areas simultaneously
while the animals perform this
discrimination and here what we found is
the red bar is performance of the Deaf
animals and the blue bar is performance
of the deaf animals when all four areas
were simultaneously activated once again
you can see the threshold comes up goes
up or performance gets worse in these
animals when these four areas are all
deactivated at the same time now let's
look at what happens when you look at
individual deactivations to each four of
these areas in the first panel in a you
can see that there is no difference in
performance when the posterior auditory
field was yeah it was the activated
bilateral which is in contrast to the
previous task we just looked at where
the posterior auditory field is so
important we also don't see any change
in performance during the activation of
a1 in the lower left or AF and the lower
rate however you do see a big change in
performance during the activation of the
dorsal zone or area DZ and in fact what
you'll see is performance gets worse or
threshold goes up during bilateral
deactivation of the dorsal zone so here
you can see that in the and the deaf
animals performance gets worse
following bilateral deactivation of the
dorsal zone but let's look at the
comparison once again
performance of the hearing animals is
shown in the green bar and performance
in the deaf animals is shown in the
height of the red bar and the height of
the blue bar shows performance of the
deaf animals while the dorsal zonals
bilaterally deactivated so what you can
see is that the advantage of the deaf
animals had went away while the dorsal
zone is bilaterally activated and
performances now don't know different
from that of the hearing animals so once
again what's a special about the dorsal
zone well at the time we we conducted
these experience we didn't actually know
much about what the dorsal zone
contributes the auditory behavior but
since that have done some experiments
looking at the direction of acoustic
motion and found that there are profound
deficits in the direction of acoustic
motion discrimination when you actually
bilaterally deactivate the dorsal zone
so in fact the dorsal zone actually
contributes to acoustic motion
processing and hearing animals but the
deaf animals is actually contributing to
a visual motion
discrimination or local is a history
visual motion processing so let's
summarize this first study
you can actually see that we found that
they were two tasks where performance
was enhanced in the congealing of
animals that was visual detection of
peripheral field and the detection of
movement and when we deactivated the
posterior auditory field bilaterally
we've got a profound deficit on the
visual detection the peripheral field
but not in the detection of movement in
contrast when we deactivated the dorsal
zone bilaterally
we found a deficit in the detection of
movement and no deficit in the visual in
visual detection that peripheral field
this is classically known as a double
dissociation we assure that one area
contributes to a task and not the other
and vice versa so here we're actually
finding that there's a visual double
dissociation and what would normally be
auditory cortex so this region of the
brain normally doesn't contribute to any
of these functions but following the
loss of normal hearing input is now
contributing or making a key
contribution to visual functions this
led us to develop what has now been
referred to as the super modal
hypothesis and that is the cortical
areas that have been physiologically
reorganized in response to a sensory
loss such as blindness or deafness our
involved in behaviors that are similar
to those of hearing in sighted subjects
but are mediated by the replacement
modality okay so using the example of
the posterior auditory field in hearing
animals the posterior auditory field
normally is involved in auditory
localization but following hearing loss
and the Deaf animals it's now involved
in visual localization in both cases is
involved in localization it really
depends on whether audition is present
or absent okay in the second group of
studies we actually want to look at
ventral stream functions following
deafness so these functions are going to
be slightly more cognitive in nature in
this case we actually want to determine
if the learning or recall of any visual
discriminations are enhanced as a
consequence of deafness and then once
again determine what role deaf auditory
cortex may play in mediating superior
cognitive functions so to do this we're
going to look at a different set of four
areas the inter areas of a presumptive
ventral or what stream and auditory
cortex so this stream emanates from
a-one and it passes down to a two and
then into the temporal area abbreviated
or insular area abbreviated i-n this is
a presumptive what with what pathway or
ventral stream in auditory cortex so the
first aim is to determine if the
learning or recall of any visual
discriminations are enhanced as a
consequence of deafness to do this we're
going to test both deaf and hearing cats
on a battery of visual discriminations
to ascertain if the learning or recall
of any visual discriminations are
actually enhance as a consequence of
deafness so in this case all the testing
is going to be done to alternative
forced choice apparatus like you see
pictured here where the animal is
presented with one stimulus and on one
screen and a different stimulus on
another and they're going to indicate
which is the rewarded or the preferred
stimulus so the different pattern for
pairs of stimuli we're going to look at
our simple patterns complex patterns
simple objects junk objects so objects
would be three-dimensional patterns
would be two-dimensional then we'll also
look at natural scenes conspecific faces
kind of specific phases would be cat
faces do the same as the species being
studied or human faces let's look at
examples of all these so you can see
what we're talking about
excuse me first off the vision what we
found was the big difference in
processing between the congenitally deaf
animals and the hearing animals was in
the processing of faces specifically
learning the faces conspecific faces in
human faces we didn't see any difference
in the learning or recall of the other
five different classes of visual
discriminations that we looked at okay
so these other discriminations were
patterns so you can see some of the
examples of patterns that were tested at
the top left so you can see like a cross
this is a circle or triangle versus an
inverted triangle and so forth these
would be simple two-dimensional patterns
to make them more complex if you will
would be the line just below that where
either a surround or some sort of
overlying pattern like in letter D of
the lower line shows the X's over the
circle square just to make the pattern a
little bit more difficult there's we
complex patterns simple objects are what
you see in the upper left things are
three-dimensional
in this case these are children's play
blocks glued together in different
shapes and painted flat black or junk
objects a la Michigan which are
basically just things you find around
the lab and have any animal discriminate
to different objects it would presumably
be objects that they would never have
seen before
and then finally natural scenes as you
can see things you get from like
calendars and so forth would also be
scenes that laboratory animals would
probably never seen before okay so let's
look here first off at the patterns or
basically the animals ability to learn
to discriminate simple patterns in the
upper line and complex patterns in the
lower line what you're going to see here
is that the results are expressed in
what we refer to as errors to criterion
basically the animals were presented
with the two patterns one was rewarded
one was not and we're looking at how
quickly they learned to discriminate the
two and what we did was we counted the
number of errors or the mistakes that
they made in order on their way to
achieving criterion performance which
was 92 percent on two consecutive days
so once the animals reached 92 percent
on two consecutive days we had deemed
that they reached criterion performance
and then missile just countered up the
errors over the mistakes they made and
what you can see here is for the height
of each bar is mean area so criterion
for both the hearing and the deaf groups
the actual circles that you see are
performance of individual animals within
each group so it's not standard error or
standard deviation but actual
performance of those animals well you
can see the take-home messages from
these two types of patterns is there was
no difference in the ability of the deaf
or the hearing animals to learn to
discriminate either simple patterns or
complex patterns okay but here what you
see but we found the things are very
very different for faces okay so here
are two examples of conspecific faces
that the animals had to learn to
discriminate in this case these are two
different gray cats if you're not a cat
person they probably look the same to
you sure our capper she probably can
readily identify the very different
animals and then down on the bottom
would be faces of two Caucasian males
with similar colored hair and some
our facial features that the animals had
to learn to discriminate okay so here
what you find though is we look at the
ability of the animals to learn faces
the upper line is conspecific basis and
the lower is human faces but doesn't
really matter whether it was kind of
specific or human what you actually find
is that the DEF animals made fewer
errors errors to criteria than the
hearing animals and in many cases just
half as many so if you look at some of
the examples particularly for the upper
line errors to criterion for the death
panels could be around 20 where the
errors to criterion for the hearing
house we closer to 40 and this difficut
this difference difference was
significant so and it didn't but it did
not matter whether it was them
discriminating cat faces they'd never
seen before or human faces they never
seen before the difference was the same
okay but we didn't find any difference
on the ability of the animals to recall
a previously learned facial
discrimination assuming a discrimination
of any kind
so you see patterns of the top that in
two objects natural scenes conspecific
faces what you see here is data that was
collected 24 hours after they learned to
discriminate a face and we're presented
with a single block of 25 trials so this
is percent correct for that block of 25
trials but the take-home message here is
that there was no difference in the
ability of the deaf animals or the
hearing animals to remember faces that
they previously learned to discriminate
so there was no advantage for the deaf
animals in remembering in remembering
faces they learn discriminate but there
was an advantage of the learning of them
okay so to summarize this this aim for
this study the Kadena deaf calves have
learning and recall abilities similar to
hearing cats on most of the
discriminations we tested simple and
complex patterns simple and junk objects
and natural scenes however the
congenitally deaf cats have learning but
not recall abilities superior to the
hearing cats on conspecific faces on
human faces so there clearly seems to be
something special about faces so in the
second day we're going to determine what
role deaf auditory cortex may play in
mediating these superior cognitive
functions were specifically the ability
to learn new face
to do that we're gonna deactivate
specific sites and deaf auditory cortex
while the deaf cats perform the visual
discriminations for which they possess
enhanced cognitive abilities so once
again we're look at these four areas of
the presumptive ventral or what
processing stream here you can see
thermal reconstructions of the regions
that were deactivated you can see the
location of for cooling loops in the
upper left-hand panel and you can see
obviously the exact same thermal scan we
were looking at before and how well
localized the actual individual T
activations are both for a 1 for a 2 for
area T and for area I n okay so this
line is just to remind you what the
normal pattern looks like for the face
discriminations we actually saw this
slide a little while ago and you can see
that the normal pattern for face
discriminations that the Deaf cats have
about half as many areas to criterion as
the hearing cats so just kind of
remember this pattern as normal okay so
the first thing we're going to do is
we're going to deactivate all four areas
while the animals learn new console and
human face discriminations and when we
do this what you see is that the normal
pattern is unidentified no longer and in
fact the deaf animals now have as many
errors to criterion is the hearing
animals so we deactivate all four of
these sites we see that the advantage
that the deaf animals has went away
remember this is the advantage of the
deaf animals have normally when we
deactivate all four areas together the
advantage completely disappears and this
is obviously this is a book for
conspecific and for human faces now we
actually want to look at what are the
contributions of each one of these four
areas individually okay so here in the
upper line you see performance of
learning conspecific faces during
bilateral deactivation of a one below
that is the learning of conspecific
faces during bilateral dehydration of a
two and then by our deviation of area T
and the bottom line is bilateral
Declaration of area and what you can see
is for a and a
that it seems to be the normal pattern
of learning the death animals are better
than the hearing animals or they fewer
errors to criteria and similarly you see
that on the bottom line for I am however
for this area T and the third line from
the top you see that the advantage has
gone away okay there is no more
performance advantage for these animals
when you bilaterally deactivate area T
and the other areas don't seem to be
making little if any contribution to
this enhanced face discrimination
learning now this is what we saw with
conspecifics you see the exact same
thing with human faces the upper two
lines are area a1 and area a2 and
performance there seems to be pretty
normal but the deaf animals have an
advantage over the hearing animals
similarly in the lower line for area I
in you can see the deaf animals have an
advantage over the hearing animals but
once again for the human face
discrimination learning you see that
bilateral deactivation of area T means
that there is no performance advantage
for the Deaf animals the advantage goes
away now a unique aspect of these
experiments is that we cannot only do
bilateral deactivations but we also do
unilateral T activations to see if a
function is lateralized to one
hemisphere or the other on the top line
you can see bilateral deactivation of
area T for con specific face learning
and you see the advantage goes away the
second line is a unilateral deactivation
of area T in the left hemisphere and you
can see that there is no performance
advantage for the deaf animals and the
bottom line is you know the unilateral
deactivation of area T and the right
hemisphere and here you can see that the
advantage persists so what this seems to
indicate is that it's specifically left
area T that is essential or performing
an essential function for the enhanced
learning of faces and the deaf animals
and it's not right area T so Y area T
what do we actually know about area T
and hearing animals well previously work
we've done looking at discriminations of
different tones noises and vocalizations
in this case us they're casting would be
owls and cats can discriminate each
other based on their meow what we find
is that hearing animals bilateral
deactivation of area T
results in conspecific vocalization
deficits that means they lose the
ability to discriminate each other based
on vocalizations the unilateral
deactivation of left but not right area
T causes deficits during con specific
vocalization discriminations so you see
in the right-hand group or the right
histogram a warm performance is
dark-green the latest performance is
bilateral and just to the left of that
is left unilateral deactivation and just
to the right of that is right unilateral
deactivation so you can see there is no
difference with right unilateral
deactivation but there is a difference
not to chance levels but there is a
significant drop in performance during
left area t discrimination of
vocalizations so that is in a normal
hearing animal area team makes a
critical contribution to vocalization
discrimination specifically in the left
hemisphere so to summarize this part we
find that by letter of the activation of
area T eliminates the faster learning of
conspecific in human faces identified
and death compared to hearing cats these
enhanced face learning abilities were
further localized to area tape of the
left hemisphere third that left area T
and hearing animals is critical for
discriminating conspecifics acoustically
via vocalizations while left area T and
deaf cats is critical for discriminating
conspecifics visually via faces finally
cross normal plasticity identified area
T reveals a cortical region that may be
critical in discriminating individuals
okay so let's summarize the results from
these two studies in the first study we
saw four people we examined the
contributions of PAF and the dorsal zone
and the final study we looked at the
contributions of area T and we're going
to look at the contributions that are
normally made by these areas at hearing
animals and in deaf animals and then
what's the common behavior between the
two so we consider the posterior
auditory field in hearing animals it
normally makes a contribution to
acoustic localization in deaf animals it
normally makes a contribution to the
visual localization so the common
behavior between the two is low
zatia for the dorsal zone we saw that in
hearing animals it makes an important
contribution to acoustic motion
processing in the deaf animals and makes
an important contribution to visual
motion processing therefore motion
processing is the common behavior
between the two different conditions and
then finally for STV and then finally
for area T hearing animals we found that
area T makes an important contribution
to localization discrimination and then
the deaf animals that makes an important
contribution to face discrimination so
here we've proposed in the common
behavior is the ability to discriminate
individuals either visually or
acoustically ok so the idea here is the
cross modal reorganization that can
generally death switch is the sensory
but not the behavioral roles of auditory
cortex so they're common behaviors that
are present regardless of whether
there's normal auditory input or not so
the idea here is if you look at this
brain that we saw earlier in the
presentation this is a lateral view of a
cat brain the yellow areas are auditory
cortex and normally are making
contributions to auditory behaviors but
following hearing loss and the deaf
animal what you find is their particular
areas that are now making contributions
to visual processing and there are other
areas contributions as a matter of
sensory processing which we didn't cover
today so we saw that the dorsal zone the
posterior auditory field and area T are
all visual areas as from what we saw
today the field of the anterior
Castilian sulcus abbreviated FAS also
makes important contributions to vision
during deafness and the anterior
auditory field makes important
contributions to cement a sensation
processes following deafness so
hopefully what you remember from today's
presentation is that congenitally deaf
cats have specific visual abilities
they're superior to hearing cats and
these animal these enhancements are
really no different from that of human
subjects second regions of deaf auditory
cortex are responsible for mediating the
enhanced visual abilities of the
congenitally deaf so in absence of
normal auditory input other senses such
as vision and savanna sensation do
utilize the under-under purpos'd
auditory cortex in a deaf side
and finally cross-modal reorganization
that can generally def which is the
sensory but not the behavioral roles of
auditory cortex I'd like to thank all of
our funding sources for helping us
accomplish this these studies and also
like to thank professor Alex Meredith
shown on the left a collaborator at
Virginia Commonwealth University in the
States and Professor Andre crow a
longtime collaborator who's at the
medical university of hannover germany
who's pictured on the right I also need
to thank all the people are doing all
the heavy lifting on these studies in
the lab specifically Nicole Shabo Blake
Butler Carmen Wong dance dolls bird
Trisha Brown
Melanie cook if you'd like to get any
other information or read more about
these studies our website is cerebral
Systems dossier and address and email
address is provided on this slide thank
you very much thank you dr. lumber for
that wonderful presentation we
appreciate it
we will now start the live Q&A portion
of the webinar if you have any questions
you'd like to ask please do so now just
click on that ask a question drop-down
box located on the far left of your
presentation window type that question
into the box that appears on the screen
and click the send button well answer as
many as we have time for during the end
of the presentation here so let's take a
look at our current questions already
coming in from our audience members our
first question is do the inputs to
auditory cortex change following in the
death this is a great question obviously
as you mentioned before at the end of
all these experiments in addition to
electrophysiological recording we're
also doing pathway tracer injections
into these areas so that we can
ascertain if there's been any changes in
inputs and outputs to these areas
following the loss of hearing so the
interesting thing is our original
hypothesis was that there would be
larger and
it's from visual parts of the brain
following hearing loss and surprisingly
we're not really finding strong changes
in the overall pattern of inputs that
you would normally see to auditory
cortex surprisingly the input seemed to
come from the same constellations of
cortical and thalamic areas that you'd
expect
however we are seeing some quite
interesting changes in the outputs for
auditory cortex which are seem to be
much more significant than changes in
the inputs specifically we've been
changed looking at changes to technical
structures like the superior colliculus
and the inferior colliculus and we do
see quite profound changes in the
outputs from auditory cortex following
hearing loss but not really big changes
in the inputs to auditory cortex that
was a great question thank you and
here's our next question dr. la Mer why
do other senses only take over certain
regions of auditory cortex and not
others this is also a good question our
original hypothesis was that if auditory
cortex in the Deaf was going to be
involved in mediating superior visual or
somatosensory functions that it would be
distributed over multiple areas and we
were actually surprised to see how well
localized it is to specific areas and
that this idea of an area having a
particular behavioral function like
localization or motion or identity
processing and that basically that stays
and then you just substitute a different
modality and for that same function so
we were surprised that things were that
well localized we were expecting things
to be much more distributed and also I
mean we're expecting that when we find
this with with other tasks we just
haven't gotten to them yet Thanks thank
you very much and I want to also thank
our audience members for their great
questions coming in and remind them that
any question is not answer today will be
answered via email here's our third
question how long can the brain be
deactivated
with cooling uh the longest the longest
we've had a region the activated cook
was about two hours for most of our
behavioral work a region will be
activated generally for say 20 or 30
minutes two hours on the outside we
really haven't done any experiments to
see what's the outer window for
reversibility that is you know how long
can we have an area deactivated and then
have everything returned completely to
normal but we really don't have any
experiments that require us to have a
region deactivated for more than two
hours I mean that's that would be a
really long time for us but we've found
complete reversibility within that sort
of timeframe so what the outer window
might be is still unknown but the window
that we're working with is much larger
than anything we would presently need
thanks that was a good question thank
you our next question from our audience
is do similar changes occur in visual
cortex of the blind yeah that's a really
good comparison yeah a lot of obviously
that a lot of studies also done on
visual cortex in blind individuals and
very similar changes are being found in
blind individuals whether that's using
human functional imaging studies looking
at activation in visual cortex of the
blind or looking at animal studies in
blind animals as well very similar kind
of this idea of a task specific
organization to the brain is being found
and also similar enhancements to vision
or somatosensory function actually to
audition or somatosensory function have
been found in individuals that are blind
so we find a lot of parallels between
studies done in the deaf and studies
done in the blind that was a great
question thank you for that and we have
time for one more question from our
audience
here's an interesting one why cotton why
conduct these studies on cats as opposed
to rats or mice
oh yeah that's very important
well we and others have found that the
wiring of the brain of ruins is very
different from that of higher mammals
such as monkeys cats ferrets and when
I'm sure if it's just got to do with the
with the sheer size of the brain or if
it's more fundamental but in many cases
what's been identified in rodent brains
is that their direct connections between
say primary visual cortex and primary
auditory cortex or primary somatosensory
cortex and primary auditory cortex and
these connections don't exist in higher
order mammals so if you really want to
understand the consequences of say
blindness or deafness you'd probably
want to do that in a model organism
where the brain is wired more like a
human brain and and not have you know
unusual connections that aren't are
typical of more highly developed mammals
so that's why you find more of these
studies done in mammals such as monkeys
cats ferrets as opposed to mice and rats
it's just that the brain is different
thanks for that question dr. Lambert
thank you again for your presentation
and for your important research and I'd
also like to take the opportunity to
think lab routes for making today's
educational webcast possible before we
go I want to remind everyone that
today's webcast will be available for
on-demand viewing through June 2018
you'll receive an email from lab roots
letting you know when the webcast will
be available for replay please share
that announcement with your colleagues
you may have not been able to join us
today for this live event that's all for
now and thank you for joining us we hope
to see you again soon bye-bye